-Welcome back, everybody.
Questlove and I are about to
play a fun and frightening game.
This is the jump scare
VR challenge.
-♪ Jump scare VR challenge ♪
♪ Wine edition ♪
-Playing with us tonight
is a talented actress
whose wine Avaline
is available online
and in stores
across the country.
Give it up for Cameron Diaz!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you, Cameron.
Thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-Here's how this works.
We're all going to watch
a jump-scare video
together at the same time
in our VR headsets,
while holding a full glass
of Avaline wine.
Whoever can keep their composure
the most and spill
the least amount of wine
on their white jumpsuit wins
that round.
Are you ready to do this?
-Oh, yeah.
-We have to have our eyes open?
-Oh, I'm so ready.
-Yes, yes, you have to have
your eyes open.
[ Laughter ]
Aren't you a lefty, though?
-Nope.
-I'm a lefty.
-No, you're not. Oh, hilarious.
I just have a feeling
I'm going to get soaked.
Yeah. Alright,
let's put on our VR headsets.
-Yeah.
-Oh, grab your wine first.
Probably.
-Oh, I got it, I got it.
-Wait. Oh. It's happening.
-Wait. It's happening?
-I don't know. Something --
The screen's gone dark,
but I'm holding my wine
over my crotch.
What is -- Is
everyone else doing that?
-That's what I'm doing.
-Okay.
-It's in my left hand.
[ Laughter ]
-Why? You're right-handed.
-I'm a lefty.
-[ Groans ]
♪♪
Oh.
-Oh, God. Oh, God.
-Stop.
No. Turn it off.
-Oh, you already know.
You already know.
-There's something in
the screen.
-You know, that's --
-Oh, no, no, no, no.
This is frightening.
-She's going to change
into something.
-Why? Is it blurry, too?
I don't like this at all.
[ All scream ]
-[Bleep]
-Oh, God.
-Frick! Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-I kept my composure, but that
was frightening right there.
And I don't even know if I've
ever heard you curse before.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah. Ooh.
-What happened?
-Sorry.
-I think we're okay.
-You look good.
I barely have anything on me.
-I didn't get anything on me.
-Ooh.
Alright, let's see it
in slow motion.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. No one else's wine
is over their body.
[ Laughter ]
In the slow-motion video
that we just watched.
Busted hard. No one is holding
their wine in front of them.
-Oh, we're supposed
to hold it here?
-I think so.
-I thought this was like
try to keep Jimmy dry.
That was the part --
That was the rule.
-Yeah, that's the rule.
Yeah, exactly.
Jimmy can't get wet.
I'm like a gremlin.
Alright, alright. The winner
of the first round is me.
-Jimmy.
-Yeah, sure.
I already know
where this is going.
-I'm not gonna scream.
-I don't think you're going to,
either. I think you're pretty...
Alright, hold on.
Alright, now we're ready.
[ Gasps ]
Okay. I'm already scared.
No, no, no, the power went off!
No!
-No!
-Alright. No, no, no, no.
-Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God.
Oh, did you see that?
-No. There was that sweatshirt.
[ Jimmy and Questlove scream ]
-That was okay. That was okay.
-I'm good. That was fine.
-That was just a dog.
-That was not bad.
That was a little cute dog.
-That's like literally
every morning in my house.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-No, no spillage there.
Looks like Quest though spilled
a little bit.
-I didn't spill.
-Yeah, a little bit though.
Maybe. Let's see the replay
of that one.
That one wasn't as scary.
-I think I won.
I think I got that one.
[ Laughter ]
-Quest, you spilled a little
bit. Quest, you spilled.
The winner of the round
is Cameron.
Cameron Diaz wins that round.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Alright, here we go.
Let's get our headsets on
and get ready for
the third jump scare.
-Okay, you guys.
So this one's been
a long time coming.
So we're going
to take it over here.
[ Grunts ] We're doing some
feeding in that room,
so we're kind of closed
from there.
This is a really
important clutch of eggs.
[ Grunts ]
So, I don't know how long
you guys have been following me,
but...
-What is this?
-This is actually a baby
from a baby.
-Oh, no.
[ Jump-scare sound ]
-No, it didn't scare me at all.
I'm kind of immune to the scare.
-Yeah. I'm really --
I've prepared myself.
-I prepared myself.
I wasn't scared at all.
-I didn't yell.
-I lowered my heart rate.
-Now I'm like...
-I started meditating.
-Yeah, I find it humorous.
-Yeah.
It's like, ha, ha ha ha,
ha ha ha ha.
-Let's see the replay and
see who laughed the least.
[ Laughter ]
-We're the ones --
-Your eyes were closed, man.
-We're the ones that reacted,
I was like, alright, alright.
-I was like, "Here it comes."
-Cameron Diaz wins
that one as well.
Yeah. Alright.
-I know what's gonna happen.
-Alright, here we go.
[ Wolf howling ]
Oh.
-Uh-oh.
-You know what that sound means.
-What does that mean, Jimmy?
-It's time for the final round.
Whoever wins, this wins
the whole thing, the whole game.
And also our wine glasses
will be much bigger this time.
-Bigger glasses?
Whoa. They better come
with something really --
Here, you could just put it
right in my hand.
-Okay, here we go.
-Wait. We got to hold this?
-Yeah. One hand? One hand?
-You can't hold this
in one hand.
-I don't think you can.
Wow! This is just real glass.
This is like a gallon of --
Alright.
-It's like a whole bottle of --
-Alright. This is the last one.
Here we go.
-Okay. Where's your lap, Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
[ Eerie music plays ]
-Oh, this is my favorite.
I love this one.
-Yeah, this is funny.
-This one's really good.
-Yeah, I watched this
with the kids.
-I've never seen this.
I don't like scary things
on the Internet.
-It's like snowing.
It's just scary.
-I think those are bugs.
-No. It's like --
Here's something.
-Wait. What is this?
-Ah!
♪♪
-Ah, I wasn't scared.
[ Laughs ]
Wait.
-Is that it?
-That's all?
Alright,
let's see that in slow --
[ Laughter ]
Oh [bleep] [bleep]
Get off me.
[ Applause ]
Stop stop, stop.
What's wrong with you?
-You're lucky I had wine in my
hand. I would have went boop!
-The winner of this challenge
is Cameron Diaz.
I don't know what --
Get out of here.
Thanks to Questlove,
Cameron Diaz.
We're talking to Cameron
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.